[Music]
today we're introducing two of the six
new classes in van helsing 3 the flood
estonia and the amber list the
phlogiston air is a hunter dedicated for
more destructive aspects of a weird
science he is protected by his heavy
exoskeleton equipped with deadly
explosives the amber list is a fighter
who studied the arcane manipulation of
shadows
and relies on stealth and surprise
attacks to inflict substantial damage in
the blink of an eye to do so he will use
shadow sigils that can either boost his
damage or cloak him again to prepare for
another ambush let's see how they fare
in various combat situations when you're
facing enemies from the distances are
phlogiston here you can lay down a
minefield in advance and swarm you're
approaching enemies with rockets should
they survive that you can easily blast
them away with a devastating rain of
projectiles when you players number list
you should sneak up close and use the
blink assault your attacks will receive
a huge damage bonus after you shed your
cloak of Shadows when it comes to
sustaining damage the phlogiston e'er
has it easy
his interceptive forcefield provides a
defense boost and recharges between
battles the force field can be improved
by different masteries so for example
you can make it explode when it
fully depleted the under list on the
other hand is more vulnerable so you
should avoid getting hit at all costs
luckily he can always switch back to his
life stealing abilities by using shadow
bust if the situation gets too risky the
under list can summon shadow warriors to
fight while he vanishes from sight if
you are surrounded by enemies as a flop
dystonia you have a number of
destructive choices incinerate your foes
with your flamethrower or blast them all
away with an artillery strike as a
number list you should get away from
these situations by using trail of
darkness then jump right back into the
battle with a shadow jolt spell to
freeze your foes also if you kill your
enemies in one hit you consume your
shadows sigils and you get cloaked
instantly to prepare for another stealth
attack as a phlogiston ear you will
stand strong in the fight with your wide
array of mines rockets and protective
force field and the amethyst will strike
her same fear into the hearts of his
enemies destroy them all
[Music]